SEAN HANNITY TAKES OVER AN HOUR
FROM NEW YORK.
>> Sean: SOCIAL DISTANCING, ME
AND TUCKER, GOOD TO SEE YOU,
THANK YOU.
NOW TONIGHT, IT IS CLEARER THAN
EVER WE ARE LIVING THROUGH A
TRANSFORMATIONAL TIME.
THE WORLD WILL NEVER BE THE
SAME, EVENTS OF THE LAST MONTH
ARE HAVING A SUBSTANTIAL AND
UNPRECEDENTED IMPACTS ON OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR CULTURE AND OUR
WAY OF LIFE.
BUT WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS FOR
NOW AND IN THE FUTURE AS WELL
BECAUSE THE BOOKS ARE BEING
COMPLETELY REWRITTEN ON HOW WE
ADDRESS PANDEMICS.
THAT INCLUDES TRAVEL BANDS,
PUBLIC-PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS,
TELEMEDICINE, DRIVE-THROUGH
TESTING, ANTIBODY TESTING,
BYPASSING FDA RULES, ALLOWING
THE CHOICE, AND THAT MEANS OFF
LABEL PRESCRIPTIONS AND SO MUCH
MORE.
TONIGHT, THERE IS REASON TO BE
OPTIMISTIC AND REASON TO BE
HELPFUL.
DR. DEBORAH BIRX WILL BE JOINING
US IN JUST A MINUTE.
WE ARE INCHING CLOSER AND CLOSER
TO EATING THIS VIRUS, TO
RESTARTING THE SINGLE MOST
POWERFUL ECONOMIC ENGINE IN
HUMAN HISTORY, AND SOLVING WHAT
IS A SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMIC.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT FROM
EARLIER TONIGHT, LET’S TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A ROUGH
WEEK, ROUGH MORE THAN A WEEK.
BUT THERE IS TREMENDOUS LIGHT AT
THE END OF THAT TUNNEL.
HAS SAID IT LAST NIGHT, THERE’S
TREMENDOUS LIGHT AT THE END OF
THE TUNNEL, SO MANY THINGS
HAPPENING WITH THERAPEUTICS,
WITH VACCINES, WITH THINGS THAT
WE REALLY WANT, THEY ARE ALL
WORKING SO HARD IN THIS.
>> Sean: I WANT TO MAKE ONE
THING CLEAR AS WE BEGIN, WE WILL
GET THROUGH THIS, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND AS
WE DO, WE NEED TO ALSO REMEMBER
THAT THE CURE CANNOT BE WORSE
THAN THE CRISIS ITSELF.
WE CANNOT PUT PARALYZING PANIC
AND OVER PRACTICAL PRECAUTIONS
ABOVE AMERICANS WORKING.
NOW WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS GETTING THIS COUNTRY
BACK TO WORK DOING WHAT WE DO
BEST AS SOON AS SAFELY AS
POSSIBLE.
MEANS DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN DO
TO FIND TREATMENTS AND A CURE
AND LIKE I’VE SAID, THE IDEA OF
AN ECONOMIC TASK FORCE SEEMS
LIKE THE RIGHT PATH TO ME,
BRINGING STEVE MORAN BUSINESSMEN
AND WOMEN WHO UNDERSTAND
WALL STREET AND MAIN STREET,
ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE BIG
DEVELOPMENTS ON
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
DR. OZ IS HERE WITH THAT, ALSO
DR. BIRX.
I HAVE AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE FOR
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
ANDREW CUOMO.
EARLIER TODAY, HE ANNOUNCED THAT
THE STATE MAY HAVE HIT A PLATEAU
BECAUSE NEW DATA NOW SHOWS THAT
NEW HOSPITALIZATION SAW A SHARP
DROP IN JUST THE LAST FOUR DAYS.
BY THE WAY, WE ALSO KNOW THAT
PREDICTIONS OF MODELS DIDN’T
LIVE UP TO WHAT THEY TOLD US IT
WOULD BE.
A SIGNIFICANTLY.
THAT’S GOOD.
STOCK SURGING ON THE NEWS THAT
THE OUTBREAK MAY BE CLOSER TO A
PEAK AND SO WE HAVE NEVER BEFORE
WITNESSED A HEALTH CARE
MOBILIZATION EFFORT LIKE THE ONE
WE ARE WITNESSING NOW ACROSS THE
NATION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS CHANGED THE
RULES ON HOW WE WILL EVER FIGHT
PANDEMICS HERE AND WORLDWIDE.
WRINKLY, ANDREW CUOMO AND ALL
NEW YORKERS IN THE COUNTRY
SHOULD BE THANKING THE PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE WHILE ANDREW CUOMO
WASN’T LISTENING TO HIS OWN
HEALTH CARE TASK FORCE, THAT
STRONGLY RECOMMENDED AND SAYING
YOU WILL NEED THIS, WE CAN
PREDICT THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN,
AND HE DID NOTHING AND
COMPLAINING THE PRESIDENT WAS
TAKING ACTION DELIVERING ALL THE
NEEDED AID TO NEW YORK AND IN
THE COUNTRY.
DONALD TRUMP CAME TO THE RESCUE
OF NEW YORK STATE AND DID WHAT
CUOMO SHOULD HAVE BEEN PREPARING
FOR OR de BLASIO SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PREPARING FOR A PERIOD OF
2 MILLION SURGICAL MASK,
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF FACE
SHIELDS AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS, OVER
5,000 TO NEW YORK ALONE AND ALSO
BUILDING NEW HOSPITALS IN
ADDITION TO THE EMERGENCY
HOSPITAL AT THE JAVITS CENTER
WHICH IS THE LARGEST HOSPITAL
NOW IN THE COUNTRY, ORIGINALLY
NOT BUILT FOR COVID-19, NOW THEY
ARE TAKING IN COVID-19 PATIENTS.
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS ALSO
STAFFED OF THE ENTIRE
JAVITS CENTER WITH HIS
PERSONNEL.
IN OUR GREAT THAT HOSPITAL FOR
NEW YORK AND FOR THE GOVERNOR
WHO WAS ILL-PREPARED.
WE HAVE THE USNS COMFORT IN
NEW YORK HARBOR WHICH WILL NOW
TREAT COVID-19 PATIENTS AS WELL.
THE LACK OF STATE AND
NEW YORK CITY PREPARATIONS IS
SHOCKING.
AFTER 9/11 AFTER THE FIRST TRADE
CENTER BOMBING, NUMEROUS TERROR
THREATS KNOWING THAT
NEW YORK STATE, NEW YORK CITY IN
PARTICULAR HAS THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF PEOPLE IN THE
SMALLEST GEOGRAPHICAL AREA
MAKING NEW YORK CITY THE MOST
VULNERABLE TO ANY PANDEMIC AS
CUOMO’S OWN HEALTH CARE
TASK FORCE WARNED THEM ABOUT IN
NOVEMBER OF 2015 IN DETAIL.
YOU LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING
ABOUT NEW YORK CITY, IT HAS BEEN
AN EPIC FAIL ON ALL LEVELS OF
NEW YORK GOVERNMENT.
STATE AND CITY, A DISASTER.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE AFTER 9/11,
NO EXCUSE AFTER BEING WARNED BY
A TASK FORCE, AND YOU HAD YEARS
TO FIX THE PROBLEMS.
NEW YORK NEEDS TO KNOW WHILE THE
PRESIDENT WAS WORKING WAS
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK TO MAKE
AVAILABLE MILLIONS OF DOSES OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, ALL TALK NO
ACTION GOVERNOR CUOMO WAS
PUTTING UP DANGEROUS BARRIERS
BETWEEN PATIENTS AND DOCTORS.
TODAY FINALLY, GOVERNOR CUOMO
WAS ASKED ABOUT THE DRUG, HERE’S
WHAT HE SAID EARLIER TODAY.
>> WE’VE ALLOWED USAGE OF THE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WITH THE
AZITHROMYCIN PACK IN HOSPITALS
AT THEIR DISCRETION.
WE HAD A 14 DAY LIMIT ON HOW
MUCH YOU COULD BUY.
BECAUSE SO MANY PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO BUY IT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT INCREASES
THE SUPPLY TO NEW YORK WHICH
THEY SAY THEY’RE GOING TO DO,
THEN WE COULD LIFT THE 14 DAY
LIMIT.
ANECDOTALLY, YOU’LL GET
SUGGESTIONS THAT IT HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE, BUT WE DON’T HAVE ANY
OFFICIAL DATA YET THE HOSPITAL.
>> Sean: YES, HE IS PROVIDING
YOU THE HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE JUST
LIKE HE PROVIDED YOU ALL THE
MASTS AND ALL THE VENTILATORS
AND BUILDING THE HOSPITALS AND
NOW STAFFING THE HOSPITALS
BECAUSE YOU DIDN’T LISTEN TO
YOUR TASK FORCE.
CALLING ON THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK TO IMMEDIATELY LIFT THE
PHARMACY BAN ON GETTING THIS
DRUG.
IN OTHER WORDS, PHARMACIES
BECAUSE OF AN EXECUTIVE ORDER,
THEY CAN NO LONGER FULFILL OF
PRESCRIPTION FOR
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IF A PATIENT
AND A DOCTOR THINK THAT THEY
NEED IT.
I WROTE AN OP-ED THIS WEEKEND
FOR FoxNews.com.
THIS SHOULD BE A DECISION
BETWEEN THE DOCTORS AND THE
PATIENTS, NOT GOVERNOR CUOMO OR
CONRAD de BLASIO.
AND AS DR. OZ WILL EXPLAIN IN
MOMENTS, THIS IS NOT ANECDOTAL
ANYMORE.
WE ARE NOW BEYOND THAT POINT IN
SPITE OF WHAT THE MOB AND THE
MEDIA TELL YOU.
COUNTRIES ALL OVER THE WORLD ARE
SEEING POSITIVE SIGNS INCLUDING
IN FRANCE AND CHINA AND TURKEY
AND INDIA AND ISRAEL AND MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES IN BETWEEN.
A 73% OF PATIENTS IN SPAIN HAVE
BEEN USING IT.
LET ME BE CLEAR, THIS IS
SOMETHING TO TAKE WHEN
PRESCRIBED BY A DOCTOR.
I AM NOT DR. HANNITY.
THERE ARE RISKS, SIDE EFFECTS
INCLUDE HEADACHE, DIZZINESS,
STOMACH PAIN, RASH, AND YOU
SHOULD ALWAYS MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION WITH YOUR DOCTOR.
THIS IS ABOUT SCIENCE, THIS IS
ABOUT BEING A MEDICAL DOCTOR AND
IT SHOULDN’T BE ABOUT POLITICS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOSES AND HAS
MADE MILLIONS OF DOSES AVAILABLE
EVEN MORE THIS WEEKEND TO THE
NEW YORK GOVERNOR.
I SAY IT AGAIN, LET THE PEOPLE
OF NEW YORK AND THEIR DOCTORS
DECIDE, NOT YOU.
AND WHEN YOU’RE GETTING IT FOR
FREE.
I GET IT, I UNDERSTAND, WE ALL
WANT LONG-TERM TRIALS BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, AS DR. OZ HAS BEEN
SAYING, YOU GO TO BATTLE WITH
THE ARMY WE HAVE.
WE DON’T HAVE TIME IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PANDEMIC TO HAVE A TWO YEAR
CLINICAL TRIAL.
HOLD ON, VIRUS.
WE NEED A CLINICAL TRIAL.
THAT DOESN’T WORK THAT WAY.
DOCTORS ALL AROUND THE WORLD ARE
USING IT.
WE HAVE MORE NEW INCREDIBLE
DATA, PROBABLY THE SINGLE MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE EXPERT IN THE
COUNTRY ON THIS.
I’M GOING TO GET TO THAT IN A
MINUTE.
REMEMBER, GOVERNOR CUOMO FAILED
TO ACT ON MULTIPLE FRONTS.
THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TALK AND ACTION.
THE PRESIDENT BUILT THE
HOSPITALS IN THE VENTILATORS ON
THE MASS THAN THE GLOVES AND THE
GOWNS AND EVERYTHING THAT THEY
DIDN’T PREPARE FOR NEW YORK, BUT
ANDREW CUOMO WAS GOING ALL THE
WAY BACK NOVEMBER 2015, WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN IF WE HAD AN
INFLUENZA PANDEMIC IN NEW YORK
AND HOW HE WOULD NEED TO ACT
BOLDLY, AND THEY HAD AN
OBLIGATION ETHICALLY AND
OTHERWISE TO SAVE THE LIVES OF
NEW YORKERS BY ACTING NOW.
THIS IS A FORESEEABLE PROBLEM AS
THAT STUDY CITED.
CAME TO VENTILATORS SHORTAGE,
THEY ADDRESSED IT EXPLICITLY.
IN NOVEMBER 2015, NEW YORK
HEALTH DEPARTMENT REPORT READ
"DURING A SEVERE INFLUENZA
PANDEMIC, THERE IS LIKELY TO BE
A PROJECTED SHORTFALL OF 15,783
VENTILATORS DURING THE PEAK WEEK
DEMAND.
A SHORTFALL OF NEARLY 16,000
VENTILATORS.
I SAW THIS WEEKEND, HE PUT UP
ONE OF HIS POWER POINTS THAT
SAID REQUESTED TO PURCHASE,
17,000 VENTILATORS BECAUSE HE
DIDN’T REQUEST THEM AT THE TIME.
HE REQUESTED THEM THREE WEEKS
AGO.
WHERE WAS THE RESPONSE FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHEN HIS OWN
HEALTH CARE TASK FORCE TOLD HIM
HE NEEDED TO DO IT?
WHERE WAS HIS URGENCY AFTER SUCH
AN EXPLICIT WARNING THAT
NEW YORKERS WOULD DIE?
GOVERNOR CUOMO REFUSED TO ACT
AND HE DID NOTHING.
HE DIDN’T LISTEN.
GET THIS, THE COST TO PURCHASE
THE NEEDED VENTILATORS WAS ONLY
0.4% OF HIS 2015-16 BUDGET.
AN TO THOSE WHO MIGHT WANT TO
CRITICIZE SEAN HANNITY, LET ME
SAY THIS.
I AM IN GROUND ZERO RIGHT NOW.
BORN AND RAISED HERE, LIVED ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY BUT MY FAMILY
LIVES HERE.
THOUSANDS OF NEW YORK CASES ON
LONG ISLAND WHERE I STILL LIVE.
PEOPLE I KNOW FIGHTING FOR THEIR
LIVES IN HOSPITALS RIGHT AROUND
HERE.
AND I CAN’T GO VISIT AFTER
READING THAT REPORT, IN EVERY
NEW YORKER NEEDS TO BE FURIOUS,
THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE NEED ONE TO INVESTIGATE WHY
CUOMO FAILED TO ACT AFTER THAT
DIRE WARNING.
WHY HE PREPARED NOTHING.
WHY DID BILL de BLASIO PREPARE
NOTHING.
AFTER SEEING HIM PUT UP A WALL
BETWEEN DOCTORS AND PATIENTS, I
AM APOPLECTIC.
AND EVERYTHING REPORTED FIVE
YEARS AGO IS NOW HAPPENING, THIS
IS THAT WEEK THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE WITNESSED FROM THE GOVERNOR
AND THE MAYOR DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
JANUARY 24TH, HE WAS SAYING THE
REST OF NEW YORKERS ARE LOW.
FEBRUARY 7TH CLAIMING CATCHING
THE FLU RIGHT NOW IS A MUCH
GREATER RISK THAN ANYTHING.
THE FACT IS, CUOMO WAS WARNED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND HE WAS
WRONG OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
NOW WE TURN TO MY FACTS WITHOUT
FEAR SEGMENT TONIGHT.
ACCORDING TO JOHNS HOPKINS, THE
U.S. HAS NEVER REPORTED OVER
10,000 DEATHS FROM CORONAVIRUS
WITH THE INFECTIONS OF OVER
350,000.
REMEMBER, THAT PANDEMIC AT
60.8 MILLION AMERICANS THAT
CONTRACTED THAT VIRUS AND THAT
PANDEMIC, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
HOSPITALIZED, AND 17,000 PEOPLE
SADLY DIED THERE.
THE WORST HIT AREAS INCLUDING
NEW YORK RIGHT NOW, DETROIT AND
NEW ORLEANS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED AT
TONIGHT’S BRIEFING THAT FEMA HAS
DISTRIBUTED 11.7 MILLION N95
RESPIRATORS.
5.3 MILLION FACE SHIELDS,
4.4 MILLION SURGICAL GOWNS,
22.6 MILLION GLOVES, THEY NOW
HAVE AVAILABLE 29 MILLION DOSES
OF HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
THEY HAVE NOW OVER 10,000
VENTILATORS THAT THEY ARE
DISTRIBUTING TO STATES ON A PER
NEED BASIS, STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA, WASHINGTON, OREGON
ALL ANNOUNCING THAT THEY ARE
ACTUALLY SENDING HUNDREDS OF
VENTILATORS FROM THE FEDERAL
STOCKPILE TO OTHER STATES WITH
THE VIRUS.
THESE DATES BOTH LED BY
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS INCLUDING
WASHINGTON AS WELL.
THEY ARE TO BELIEVE TO BE APPLAU
WE ARE LEARNING THE U.K.
PRIME MINISTER BORIS JOHNSON HAS
BEEN MOVED TO AN INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT HAS HIS SYMPTOMS SADLY
WORSEN.
OUR PRAYERS ARE WITH HIM.
OUR ALLIES AND FRIENDS IN THE
U.K. AND ANYONE THAT HAS
CONTRACTED THIS VIRUS.
THERE IS ALSO REASON TONIGHT TO
BE HOPEFUL BECAUSE TONIGHT, THE
KEY CORONAVIRUS MODEL WHICH IS A
MODEL THAT YOU SAW IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE HAS
JUST DRASTICALLY BEEN SHIFTED
AND CHANGED AND REDUCED IN TERMS
OF THEIR PROJECTED DEATHS FROM
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
REMEMBER, THEY WERE PREDICTING
OVER 250,000 PEOPLE DEAD.
THEY SAID IF THERE WAS NO TRAVEL
BAN, NO QUARANTINE, NO
MITIGATION EFFORTS, 2.2 MILLION
AMERICANS COULD HAVE DIED.
THEY ARE NOW DOWN BELOW 100,000.
THAT IS MORE THAN 150,000 DEATHS
THEY WERE PREDICTING JUST DAYS
AGO.
LAST WEEK AGAIN PREDICTING THE
POSSIBILITY OF 250,000 AMERICANS
DYING.
THAT’S NOT ALL.
THE MODEL NOW PREDICTS 140,000
HOSPITALIZATIONS AT ITS PEAK,
THAT’S A DECLINE OF 121,000,